welcome everyone it's very nice to see
such large audience at such late time
it's four o'clock and
coming but it's got so many people join
this presentation so I will talk
actually more about using deep learning
based techniques to analyze some aspects
of the football games and there will be
very little about football itself
unfortunately so let's start basically
my name is Jessica Moravsky I work in
the startup company sport algorithmics
that develop a system to analyze
football videos recordings of soccer
games and I also work as an assistant
professor on Warsaw University of
Technology and basically our aim is to
build a system that will help to analyze
videos or recordings of football games
it's intended for professional use for
soccer academies for soccer club clubs
and it's intended to help coach is to
help football analyst to analyze the
soccer videos basically now the work of
the football analyst but work in
football academy or in claw club is
quite cumbersome he needs to manually
watch all the games if he wants for
example to assess performance of certain
player he needs to watch all the game he
needs to look only at the parts when
this player has contact with the ball
and talk on this video only small
fragments of the game a certain player
did some action for example and then he
need to prepare an assessment of his
performance we would like to automate
the process we would like to make a
system that will track the players track
the ball where we analyze the game and
find help to find our interesting
aspects of the game like find
automatically situations where certain
player possess the ball when he kicked
the ball when he shoot at the goal we
would like also to computer
automatically compute some statistics
for example how what distance did player
run or how fast did he run on average
what was his maximum speed
our assumption is also what makes the
project much more difficult is to use
off-the-shelf CCTV cameras so we are not
working on the no video broadcast TV
broadcast where these cameras have very
high zoom and you can clearly see the
entire players bother you can see ball
from the close distance we would like to
use the CCTV cameras installed around
the play field so this is the let's say
setup you are working on we've got a
number of fixed cameras installed around
the play field
but basically capture part of the part
of the play she from high distance so we
don't have a good zoom and you would
like to analyze the game unfortunately
yet there is no deep learning system
that will do everything automatically
there is no big brain that will you know
take as an input video sequence like
that and will automatically output all
the necessary statistics player drugs
and so on you need to build it from
smaller components and each component
you can use deep learning techniques to
analyze part of the game for part of the
pipeline so basically the entire
pipeline can be split into three phases
we've got this low level processing
where we detect the ball detect players
Jersey recognize number on players
shirts base mid level processing where
we can track the ball in 3d because
using multiple cameras we can track the
ball in 3d tracking and identification
of pliers and also ways with high level
processing where we recognize aspects or
interesting events in the game is this
the path is this some if someone
shooting at the goal was it the goal and
calculate statistics in this talk I will
concentrate on a few aspects because
it's not sufficient time to discuss
every aspect of the processing I will
talk about bore and prior detection how
we can efficiently do it and about
player tracking how we can efficiently
track priors
this task like Boulder section well they
seem easy for human okay you watch their
game and you see the ball what the
problem but to write a computer program
why we do it automatically on such high
resolution videos it's not so
straightforward first of all the ball is
not always circular area when it's
kicked you've got a motion blur so it's
like a lipstick curl sometimes you can
touch the line sometimes it can touch
players bother so you can adjust the
text circles because here I've got the
ball touching the player and sometimes
you are not shown is this a ball or is
this a glove of the goalkeeper where
even human is not sure what it is
detecting players it's a bit easier
because players are usually bigger but
also have got a lot of these difficult
situations like two players can touch
each other and they can have unusual
position you know like falling or
stumbling so also you need to take care
of such situation and how did we
approach this well in terms of object
detection a lot of generic purpose
object detector already available one of
the most popular ways is this SSD 300
object detector or your object detector
and they are high quality good
performance and they are suited to
detect and large number of objects like
they can detect a dog a cat a dark a car
or a plane and IQ I've got example this
detector you can put an image and it
will give you the bounding box with
probability that this object the car
umbrella person works by good but
unfortunately for our purpose it's not
sufficient because this is a huge
network it is a huge network it's got
like 30 million parameters it's got
quite impressive performance 60 frames
per second okay more than real-time but
on quite small images 300 by 300
but 90 hundred pixel and we are working
on high resolution images that got 100
times more pixels
so performance of these generic object
detectors is not sufficient so basically
inspired by this design we build
something simpler but helps but allows
real-time processing of high resolution
videos and the tech ball and player the
design looks like that if you're
interesting in details you can look for
this paper which is going to appear on
the conference in 2020 but should be
available in archive and how it works
basically as the input we take an image
so I've got width height and three
colour channels RGB and the image goes
through this classical convolutional
neural network architecture
each of these block consists of two
convolutional layers and max pooling
so it goes through these convolutional
layers and each of this block produces
the feature map where it's got half of
the image resolution the spatial
resolution is decreased by half and the
number of channels is going up so first
block is creating the feature map that's
got like we've by 2 right by 2 and so on
I will talk about this part a little bit
later and then output from this feature
maps is fed to the classifiers
but classify is the ball this is a ball
classifier it classifies is the ball on
this particular part of the screen which
corresponds to this part so we've got
the output feature map it goes to the
ball classifier which is a simple
convolutional net work but output ball
confidence map which called spatial
resolution one-fourth of the width
one-fourth of the height of the original
image and one channel basically we value
between 0 and 1 and it says ok 1 says
very high chance where is the ball in
this place 0 blue says like leave a snow
ball here the same and supplier
well we don't need a bounding box the
ball had no the same object the same
shape almost yeah it does not vary so
much similar for the player for the
player we take the feature map from the
upper convolutional block which produces
feature map of the special smaller
spitzer map of the spatial dimension
1/16 of the original image which also
one means all red means very high chance
where is a player at this particular
position which corresponds to the
special positions on the input image
also vice a regresar also simply
convolutional from consisting of two
convolutional layers that regress is
bounding box of the players so it
regress is the position of the bounding
box at the particular location so this
is classical convolutional network
architecture like vgg Norfolk fans and
why this bottom-up top-down connections
this is based on the sphere pyramid
Network concept basically to improve the
quality of the ball detector because if
we don't have this top-down connections
the player detection will work well
without any change because the player
detection takes the input from the text
output from this block goes to the
player classifier prior aggressor but
when we go down this channel down this
line we add to the output this
convolutional block we add the
higher-level features but got higher
less receptive field and what it means
it means that the ball classifier does
not look only on the small region around
the ball like 20 by 20 pixels but it
takes into account the bigger context
without these connections the ball
classifier would only take into account
a small patch in the image like 20 by 20
pixels which be more difficult to detect
the ball if something is round okay it's
likely ball but it may be you know
something part of the advertisement the
other
playing field or maybe some marking some
I know marking on the line or some
jitter lying somewhere but if we add
this path then we take bigger receptive
field to account and the classifier can
make better decision because intuitively
can work in take take into account you
know is this round object yes is
something you know that's looking like a
player's like Mia yes okay well since
definitely ball but if this is something
round but it's not but it's you know
around some study Mudville eyes meant
it's like inaudible so this bottom
top-down path improves ball classifier
performance I won't discuss details on
the loss function Hut the network is
trained but basically just to give you a
feel feeling how it's trained it's fully
supervised training so basically what we
did and this was the most tasks on the
time-consuming task we took like a
thousand video frames from real
recordings and manually tag the player
position and manually tag ball position
in each of them it was done by a couple
of people took like two or three months
but then we've got a large training set
but we can train our model and it was a
classic stochastic gradient descent
training usual stuff with neural
networks yeah we show the input image it
was passed to the network the network
give us the prediction and we know the
ground truth we've got the ball position
and players position marked you know in
our grant roof data so we compared the
outcome of the network with the ground
truth compute the loss and then use
gradient descent to minimize the loss if
someone's interesting in details and how
this loss function look like you can
look on the for the paper and see the
details and basically training of the
network took like two days
and what are the results I would say
quite good these are results on the
publicly available data set we use this
in our paper so you can see predictions
from the network 99% confidence but this
is the player this is also quite good
you can see here I've got ways quite
difficult situation occlusion the first
player is detective 99% but okay the
network issue but this is the player the
second one is occluded
we've called like 56 confidence okay low
area because it is occluded so the
network is not sure if this is a player
or not detection of the ball is much
tougher and because were some objects
like this marking what may look like a
ball so the network has lower confidence
so the confidence level in this example
is like 22% only but the ball is
detected here as well we've got unusual
position this one is lower if he's the
player is standing the confidence like
99% because West I used unusual pose the
network was trained with the usual pose
but if the goalkeeper takes hands like
that where during the training networks
L don't seen the player having hands
like that so it's less confident but
this is the player but 80% is still
quite high in terms of the numerical
results
the usual quality measure of object
detector is average precision I mean
average precision so basically this
detector on publicly available is a
soccer dataset god 90% ball detection
accuracy 94 player detection accuracy if
we don't use this top-down connections
in detector the ball detection goes down
alibi'd 5% so adding this top-down
connections in the network design helps
with especially ball detection with the
player it's almost the same even better
but what's important the network is very
efficient
it can operate on these large
high-definition images 1920 by 1080
pixels at almost 40 frames per second so
it's real time almost real time whereas
faster a CNN it is a general-purpose
object detector available in Python for
example you can use it and fine-tune it
for your own purpose it works fine as
well but it's much bigger number of
parameters like 100 times more and it
operates on 8 frames per second so
unstop isn't for real time processing
and to see it in action
let me show so here some ball detection
we may see it from time to time there
are such ridiculous like on the foot on
players incorrect detections and they
happen so we've got some additional
post-processing steps to actually filter
out with incorrect detections or like
here it look it's something circular
near the players put feet so it was
classified as a ball but very next sport
processing steps but get rid of such
spurious detections
Oh something something's frozen
okay it doesn't doesn't want to play so
why we come back to the presentation
okay that the next component I'd like to
talk about is tracking of the players
because so far we detected only pliers
but it was separate detection and each
and every frame we've got a separate
detection these players were not linked
but what do we want to have is to have
tracks of the player to track each
individual prior through the game how he
moves so we can calculate the statistics
the distance here on his speed a very
common approach to multi object tracking
is so called tracking by detection and
it works like that so we use this
approach it was like that but we've got
the current track of the object that we
are tracking a colorful person so these
are the positions and appearance of the
object preview tracked so far you know
so we've we already tracked like in four
consecutive frames with like a player
and then we've got detection from the
new frame at time t plus one so we've
got these detection and the new frame
and what we need to do is to match the
truck with the detection here is
no-brainer
actually okay we see someone is running
here and detection at time t plus one
like that so of course this is this guy
no other option actually pizza blue so
definitely definitely they are if
definitely they are different
this one this one is white but he is far
away so it's not possible that this one
that that this one matches with this
truck but general watch may have much
more difficult situations like this one
well here it's not so easy which one of
these white guys is linked with this
truck because we've got the white player
running through this trajectory and at
time t plus one we've got two detection
but more or less March to this
trajectory so what's the problem that
needs to be solved in this multitasking
multi object tracking but too much
trajectories to detection and you can
have more difficult situation imagine I
don't know free-kick when like maybe
five or ten players just you know
squeezing one near each other and how we
can track them in such rush so basically
the approach we take is like that but
we've got the targets
it means already tracked tracks that we
already know tracks of at previous
timestamps and we've got detection at
the new time step and we want to link
these trucks with detections at the new
timestamp so what we do is we measure
similarity between the truck and the red
section
if we go back like here the similarity
is based first of all on the trajectory
in the history yeah on the previous
trajectory and the position of the
detection because okay taking into
account the trajectory and the position
of the player this free are somehow
similar to this truck because he runs
this trajectory so in the next time step
he may be here he or maybe here it's all
plausible
but also we take into account the
appearance of the player and in terms of
the appearance okay only this one is
similar to the truck because we've got
the white guy running and based on the
one white here is not so obvious because
here we've got a player running this
trajectory more likely it will be this
one because it's closer to the previous
position and maybe you know taking into
account that he moves at the similar
speed and with a similar acceleration he
likely will be here but it's possible
that he will be here in terms of
appearance well both are quite similar
so we are not sure and there can be much
complex situation so how to address this
in systematic way basically here we
employed deep networks to learn the
features of the truck and to learn this
multi cue multimodal features to compute
assess similarity between the truck and
detection actually this based on the
idea from this paper which explains
details of this process but it basically
works like that but we use recurrent
neural network to first encode the track
of the player taking into account how
his speed changes between consecutive
time steps and we take into account the
features connected with the track and
these features are based basically of
appearance of the player through each
time step we encode this using recurrent
neural networks and then combine both
these motion-based
features and appearance based features
and use the fully connected network to
compute the similarity between these
encoded features from the track and each
detection so we compute similarity
between this truck and each detection
between this track and each detection
this track and each detection and we've
got similarity yeah we've got a
bipartite graph with the similarities
between tracks and the
actions like here the numbers and now
the task is to join and to merge trucks
with detections to maximize the overall
similarity and this is a classical
algorithm used for this it's called
Hungarian algorithm is very efficient
algorithm basically to march 11th to by
paragraphs to maximize to maximize some
measure I won't go into details of these
components they are based basically on
this publication but it looks like
Voivod to encode the player appearance
we just take the player bounding boxes
from previous detections pass from CN n
convolutional network to compute
features first and then pass the
resultant features to recurrent network
to compute a combined combined
description to combine embedding that
describes the player appearance and then
we use fully connected network to
compare this with the player appearance
in the next time step and similarly with
the most player motion ok I think I'm
running out of time so I will stop at
this moment so other any questions
thanks for their speech I have a
question have you tried to connect
somehow the videos from the different
CCTV cameras because you told that one
cameras is only a part of the playing
card so so so maybe you should connect
the video from the other camera stood to
have have a look at the yeah we take
this into account because in the basic
setup we've got
like four cameras and four corners were
two cameras looking at each side and
then we actually went we've got the
sections we project them onto the pitch
onto the plane because the cameras are
calibrated so we can transfer
coordinates from the camera point of
view to the world coordinate system and
we've code we project them onto the
common plane common ground I would say
this is also used for 3d ball position
recovery because then having detecting
the ball from two cameras we can
triangulate the ball position and then
we can compute if the ball then we can
compute the 3d ball coordinates so if
the ball on the ground or is this you
know kick above I know that you haven't
mentioned that part but is the concept
of determining if something is a path
shot or let's say a slide is also based
on the manually labelled data set or do
we have some kind of logic that we apply
there are two approaches one is to use
some simple heuristic I would say
because we can track if we track the
ball and we can track the player we can
see if you know the ball has the contact
with the player if this changed the
trajectory for example and we can based
on the simple heuristic we can classify
if this was a pass for example Oh
actually heuristic to detect if it was
the goal is kind of a backward because
we can detect if the ball was placed in
the middle of the playing field and this
means that it had to be you know a goal
earlier when the ball is taken but we
also experiment with the machine
learning based approach but it's still
kind of experimental what about fall if
something is someone falls it's
interesting but at the moment we do not
consider this possibly I think it could
be with the manual labeled data because
you need a couple of examples when the
two people are one people is lying on
the ground with a high chance with
something happened but you cannot
classify you know from this resolution
images you cannot tell if this is was a
fall or someone just stumbled against
his own foot and feet and fell down
do you consider joining other sources of
information to your visual like GPS
trackers there were some experimental
GPS trackers they are used now for track
key to keep track of the players
performance
I mean how fast he runs and what the
distance clearance but the spatial
resolution for the subjects that
frequently changed the direction or do
the sudden movement is not sufficient
you've got like then I know a couple of
meters it looks better when the GPS is
using the car because you someone you
know use the algorithm to somehow smooth
out the path you know that the car is
not you know jumping yeah so you can
extra interpolate and smoother the path
and it's quite accurate but for the
subject wet change the position very
frequently and very quickly it's not
accurate it's like I don't know five
maybe ten meters accuracy so it's not
sufficient to establish it may help with
I don't know maybe with tracking a
little bit but it's not sufficient to
tell if someone has a contact with a
ball or not
did you try to use less than four
cameras to 3d trick I mean two are
necessary I haven't tried this I've read
one paper with someone use one camera to
establish 3d position of the ball doing
trajectory analysis because if the ball
goes like you know parabola movement it
means it has to be kicked up and down or
maybe someone you know do this trick and
kick the ball give the rotation and it
spins on the ground but goes like
parabola so but usually the parabola
that the parabolic trajectory indicates
vets in the air but we haven't tried
this did you try to use pose estimation
you try to use pose yeah yeah there were
some experiments with this yeah we let's
say in the production system we are
we've had such functionality players do
you use only 2d tricking or also try to
trick drums in 3d try to trick Tori's
for players no other players you want to
do today because this 3d is you know
very frequent so we assume they're on
the playing ground okay sometimes
someone can jump and fly with the head
but okay it will be some error or than
in position estimation but we'd say
accept it thank you
you said to have some problems with the
ball recognition because of the of the
field
have you tried to filter out the field I
would say in production system we've got
certain post-processing steps basically
when clean these results and this is one
of them to just filter the field out so
to only then focus on the detection
within the play field yeah that's one of
the steps because as you seen there were
very couple of false detections like the
ball is detected whether player feet is
and so this needs to be and also
sometimes we've got like spare balls
lying near the playing field especially
in the training game so this all must be
filtered out after recognition because
you know sometimes when you've got like
ball butts kicked
outside the playing field we don't want
to lose it immediately because sometimes
it's kicked outside and we want at least
to keep track of it at least to see that
you know but it goes outside the city
trajectory so we don't want to
rigorously cut out the field
Thanks you mentioned detecting the
player numbers from the jerseys so how
well does that actually work and can you
for example track player statistics over
well in practice in depends on the
resolution of videos with these videos
it's extremely difficult to recognize
bad jersey numbers so in the setup when
you've got more cameras like maybe six
cameras two additional cameras at the
side of the field then you can for our
purpose we use the data set that got
about a about 8,000 frames from
different matches from different playing
fields to provide the depth diversity
and this one matches by the professional
football clubs but it was not a
consecutive you are we because in the
consecutive video usually i've got the
same lighting you know the same jersey
colors so we would like to provide
diversity so it were just selected
frames from a number of matches to
provide a diversity because if we train
this on 8,000 frames from one match and
then there you know where different
jerseys it will fail very likely because
they haven't seen guys if for example
there were different lighting conditions
it will also very likely fail so the
diversity of the data is key thank you I
guess this is thank you
[Applause]